Uh, welcome to the DDPS seminar,
everyone. Before we
uh introduce our invited speaker, let's
go over some rules as usual.
First of all, please mute yourself
during the talk. If you have immediate
questions, you're welcome to unmute and
ask. Or otherwise, please use the chat
room to post your questions so that we
can address them in the Q&A session at
the end.
Second, today's seminar is open to
external audience, so no classified
discussion is allowed. Finally, the talk
will be recorded and uploaded to our
YouTube channel.
Now, let me introduce our speaker.
It is an honor to host Christopher
Rackauckas, who is the
uh vice president of modeling and
simulation at JuliaHub, the director of
scientific research at Pumas AI,
co-PI of the JuliaHub at MIT, and the
lead developer of the
SciML open-source software organization.
For his work in mechanistic machine
learning, his work is credited for the
15,000 times speed up of NASA launch
services simulations, and recently
demonstrate a 60 times to 570 times
acceleration over Modelica
tools in HVAC simulation,
earning increased the US Air Force
Artificial Intelligence Accelerator
Scientific Excellence Award.
He is the lead developer of the Pumas
project and has received a top
presentation award
at
um at every ACoP in the last 3 years for
improving methods for uncertainty
quantification,
automatic GPU acceleration of mixed and
nonlinear mixed effects modeling, and
machine learning assist uh construction
of the NLME
models with deep NLME. For these
achievements, Chris received the
Emerging Scientist Award from ISOP.
Today, he will talk about generalizing
scientific learning and differentiable
simulation beyond continuous models.
Please enjoy the wonderful talk. Now,
without further ado, let me hand over to
Christopher. Yeah, thank you. I mean,
I'll I'll I'll jump right into this.
Thank you for the nice introduction. So,
what I want to talk about today is
scientific machine learning, right? And
what scientific machine learning is is
uh you know, I think that this this
seminar everyone's kind of familiar with
it, but the core idea behind scientific
machine learning is that you know, you
have this information in your scientific
models that you don't necessarily have
in your data. So, for example, you know,
with general relativity, there is no
data set that you know, kind of
encapture captures, you know, what
general relativity is, right? You know,
there is no 3 billion line website that
you know, like Google what Google has
for general relativity. There are
thousands of experiments that have shown
us that it's true, there isn't that data
set, right? So, if we want to build
these AI systems that are you know,
correct and predictive, what we want to
do is we want to be able to use that
knowledge as though we had data without
having to require that we just go out
there and gather that data, right? So,
how do we do that? How do we build a
machine learning kind of system that is
incorporating all of the knowledge that
we know and using that as a starting
point, and then using our data to then
go beyond the pieces that we know. This
is what we're doing with scientific
machine learning. And the core point of
what I want to hit here on here is that
differentiable simulation is very the a
very specific way of doing scientific
machine learning, and I want to talk
about how differential simulation
is hard, but it's worth developing more
time in, right? So, you know, I want to
really develop what differential
simulation is, why it's important, why
it's a hard way of doing scientific
machine learning, but why it has a lot
of payoff. And so, first of all, what is
our approach to scientific machine
learning? A lot of what I'll be talking
about today will be in this this realm
of these universal approximator
differential equations, also kind of
short-handed to universal differential
equations. The core idea behind them is
it's it's a very general object where
you say, I have differential equations
which are defined in part by universal
approximator. So, what's a universal
approximator? A universal approximator
is any kind of object that is a
representative of space of functions
from Rn to Rm. So, a neural network is
your classic example where there is the
universal approximator theorem which
says that for sufficiently large neural
network, so sufficiently large in terms
of the the size of the hidden layers or
the number of hidden layers,
um then with a sufficiently large neural
network, you can approximate any
possible function. It will
you can find weights of the neural
network such that its inputs go out to
the outputs such that over the whole,
you know, over a whole domain omega, f
of x uh f of x is a you know, neural
network of x is approximately f of x
uh for all, you know, x in there with
within some epsilon, right? So, there's
a way to be able to formalize that this
this property that you know, a
sufficiently large neural network can
approximate any any possible function
that's sufficiently large. The reason
why neural networks are used for a lot
of these cases is because they overcome
curse of dimensionality. So, for
sufficiently large uh dimensions, uh
they might be a nice object to do this,
but it's not the only object that we use
here. Uh there's also you can also make
use of polynomial chaos expansions, you
can make use of, you know, Legendre
expansions, you can use Fourier series.
All of these things are function
approximators. Now, a lot of them are
designed in 1D, and so the if you use a
use a tensor product approach to build
up these function approximators like a
Fourier series into higher dimensions,
you have exponential growth in the
number of terms. This is the curse of
dimensionality. And so, in some cases we
use some things that overcome curse of
dimensionality, other cases you don't.
But the the core idea here is that you
have function approximators. You have
things that can stand in for functions
that you don't know. And what you do is
you build models that that make use of
all this information you know. So, here
for example is a version of
Lotka-Volterra. So, we have a a version
of Lotka-Volterra where we say, you
know, x is the number of of bunnies, and
if I leave bunnies alone, I get
exponentially more bunnies. And if I
leave wolves alone, I get exponentially
less wolves over time. And I there
there's something more to this model
that I don't know. There is something
there's something extra, and
and whatever this extra thing is, it's
it's a it's
who knows? It's something that happens
when we put rabbits and wolves together,
but you know, they never teach you that
in elementary school for some reason.
So, what happens when we put rabbits and
wolves together? That's what this model
is saying. And so, what we then do is we
we we train this this model. We right we
train this neural network, this function
approximator, to capture the thing that
we did not know how to model, right? Um
and so, that's that's step one, right?
So, and once you do that, you then have
a
computational representation of the
thing that you did not know how to
model, right? So, you you know, you
don't necessarily know what it is, but
you have a object a computational object
that is able to do input-output
relationships
uh such that the thing that you did not
know how to model is correctly chosen to
now match the data. So, it's it
once it's trained, it becomes a function
of the you know, becomes an
approximation to the function that you
did not otherwise know how to write
down, right? And now, what can you do
with that? Well, you can do all sorts of
analyses, right? You can say, you know,
understand the sensitivities of the
piece of the model that you that you did
not know. You can find its Jacobian. You
can you know, you can do all these
things that you would want to do with a
model just on the thing that you
previously did not know how to model. Um
and one of the things that we then
commonly do is we do perform a symbolic
regression, right? We we we say, well,
you know, now that we've learned uh in
in such a way that we've made use of all
of our prior information, let's now try
to understand that that model element um
in terms of some more primitive pieces,
some pieces that are representative of
mechanistic portions, which we if we
were to write a model ourselves, we
would use these these these pieces,
right? And so, you can then do this kind
of symbolic regression process and have
it spit out uh equations which are more
more readable, and they actually tend to
improve the generalizability of the
approach as well. So, in the to really
kind of understand this entire approach,
I want to kind of walk through this step
by step. So, here uh we start with just
a standard machine learning, right? So,
the standard machine learning uh
approach here that we're just going to
do is a neural ODE, right? Just pure
machine learning. U prime equals a
neural network, right? So, we're saying,
learn any possible function such that
I've represented this time series. Um I
go from 0 to 21 days worth of data,
right? So, I just learn from 0 to 21
days, just that many data points. I fit
the model and extrapolate forward. And
this is uh the first uh data from the
first 21 days in the Wuhan region of
China from the COVID-19 outbreak. And
now, you look at this and you go, well,
the the lines for the estimated from the
from the model are completely not
fitting the data at all after the
training uh regime, right? Um and that
you you are right, this is what happens
with machine learning, right? Machine
learning does not at necessarily act
extrapolate well to out outside of its
data set. So,
So, what what what what what I'm saying
here is that, you know, we have a lot of
prior information though. Like I told
you that this is an epidemic model, and
so when you look at this, you go, well,
of course that's the start of an
exponential growth, right? But the
machine learning model does not know
that information, right? We just told
the machine learning model, hey, here's
a here's a bit of data from the start of
a pandemic, go for it, right? It doesn't
even know what a pandemic is. It's just
it's fitting the data and it's just
extrapolating forward. So, what happens
if we tell it a little bit about what a
pandemic is? So, here now we have this
form of a universal ODE. So,
you know, so this is a version of a one
of these epidemic models where we now
have a susceptible individuals, that's
S. We have the susceptible individuals
become exposed, the exposed individuals
become infected, over time they either
recover or they die, right? So, this is
the SEIRD model. Now, one of the
interesting things that happens when we
go to this kind of mechanistic model
form is that we now can use
heterogeneous data and prior information
inside of this process, right? So, for
example, we can know a lot of the
details about some of the the ratios
between some of the reaction rates in
this model because they can be directly
estimated from what percentage of people
are what percentage of people die versus
recover, right? So, we don't need to
actually use our time series to get a
lot of these values. We can use prior
information to be able to say, well, the
percentage of folks who
died from this disease is, you know, mu
and you know, it's so you can start to
write down these values directly from
other sources of information, right? So,
now we're bringing in other information
in a in a scientific way where you where
you're using all the knowledge that we
have, but the piece that that I want to
highlight here is that when we're
talking about something like, you know,
COVID-19 exposure, that was very
dependent on the region of the world
that you were in, right? So, for
example, you know, if you're in China
versus if you're in Sweden versus if
you're in Italy versus you know, which
state of the United States you're in,
they're completely different exposure
patterns to
to to the virus. And so, writing down a
simple equation for what how exposure to
COVID-19 occurred is not necessarily
easy to do.
But, what we can do is we can say, well,
we know a lot about this model, but the
piece that we don't know how to model is
the exposure term. So, let's just make
that one exposure term be our neural
network, you know, that the function
that we did not know how to model. Let's
put a neural network right there, and
now we have all the info all the prior
information we have, we have a machine
learning model extending it, and then
from that we're able to then see that if
it's just 0 to 21 days worth of data, we
extrapolate forward and we can
extrapolate much better, right? We're
able to get about 20 days of of
extrapolation, right? And so, that the
key key here is that we're using a lot
of other prior information, you know,
it's like we're we're not gaining
something for free, we are putting more
into the system and getting more out of
it. But, there's there's other more
concrete ways to also be able to
understand this. So, if our if our
neural network is always outputting a
positive value, so we just, you know,
make the last layer be a square a square
function or an absolute value, then what
what we know is just looking at the
equations is that S' is always negative.
And so, just from this information, we
can actually infer a lot of things. So,
what we have is a model that starts with
an exponential growth phase, and then E
will go up and then it'll have a peak
and go down, so it'll have a single
peak. And so, you can think about this
is now, you know, the world of machine
learning was about function
approximators, right? That's where I
started. But, by design what I've done
now is I said, here is a form for
universal function approximation where
it is functions which have a start with
an exponential growth phase and then
have a single peak, right? So, I mean
that that essentially encoding the types
of properties that we know to be true
with epidemic type models.
And and so, you know, that's you know,
there different ways to think about it,
you know, that hey, I made this model as
epidemicness possible, you know, that's
more high level, but also
mathematically, I've restricted the
function space that I'm allowed to be
fitting functions of. And so, from the
same amount of data, if my true function
is supposed to be living in this
function space which I've which I've
restricted to, then what I've done is I
just made it so that way I more easily
can be finding the right function
because I'm finding a function from a
subset of the larger set of all possible
functions, right?
Now, the last stage of of this universal
differential equation process is to do
the prior with the post analysis. So,
this is this is always an interesting
step. So, what we do here is we say,
well, we've trained this neural network
in such a way where it captures all of
our prior knowledge, right? So, we we've
captured all of our prior knowledge
inside of the way that we've trained
this this this exposure term. So, now
let's actually represent it down into,
you know, equations, right? Now, why do
we not start directly with writing out
down all the equations? Well, because
that can have curse of dimensionality.
You can have, you know, there's
exponentially many ways or
combinatorially be many ways you can
write down, you know, these
the these high dimensional functions,
right? But, in this form, we can do the
training process where we've taken into
account everything that we know, all of
our prior knowledge. We've once we once
we've found this neural network, we can
start to poke at it and just say, what
did it actually learn? Um
and here what we could see is that, you
know, I let this neural network be a
function in this case of S of I and D.
And one of the interesting things is it
comes out and it says, well, the best
fitting function here is a function of S
and I and you leave D out, which makes
sense because for COVID-19, exposure to
the disease was not dependent on the
number of people who've died. The people
who have died, they did have the
disease, but they are no longer
infecting individuals, they're no longer
exposing them, right? And so, this is
something that I can directly read out
from the sparse identification. Now
again, the interesting thing here is
that because there is so much
mathematical model around the object,
you can actually interpret it, right?
Because it's now there there is a lot of
interpret, you know, there is model
around it. It's not a completely
amorphous object, it is a amorphous
black box within a interpretable piece.
So, as you start to learn more
information about that black box, you
start to and how it interacts with the
rest of the model, then you are starting
to learn what you did not know how to
model, right? this piece of information
like, oh, D is you know, this exposure
is not a function of D, this is a this
is a type of, you know, a a a type of
scientific hypothesis, right? Now, the
the reason why I think that this is
interesting is cuz it allows for
scientists in the loop, right? We're not
just doing this in like a purely, you
know, trust the machine learning has
learned something. You can actually get
some information out to then then be
able to go back to the lab and say, it's
made a prediction about what what needs
to be true for this this exposure term
to be acting the way it is. Let's
actually go double-check this, right?
Now, the other thing that happens here
is that you actually get have some
improved generalize-ability. So, we kind
of see across the board that when you do
the sparse
sparsification process, you do tend to
improve the generalize-ability over just
having the pure neural network. And
there's a lot of other a lot of reasons
for that.
Kind of comes down to some of the
properties of extrapolation of of
polynomials. And if anyone wants to ask
it's something that that we haven't been
able to prove, but we have some good
ideas of the direction for how to to for
what to do there.
So, yeah, so so when I see a question
here, so say the neural network is
convolutional with arbitrary channels
and feeds.
How to best combine T and X in in this
case? I I will go into to some some uses
of conv and nets or in convolutional
operators for PDEs a bit later, so I'll
go back to that. For the COVID
prediction example, how do you determine
the functional form of the internal
sparse regression? Yeah, so so we have
to make we we have to to choose a, you
know, for example, a library of
functions that we want to do the sparse
regression to. It could be things like,
you know, every combination of
polynomials, cosine, sine, you know,
trigonometric functions, exponentials,
and you know, earth like, you know,
so you do have to make make a choice
there about how expansive you want that
dictionary to be and then you you you
simplify it down. But, in general, I
mean, that's that's one of the
algorithms involved here.
You know, I I could go into more detail,
but it's it's really one just one one
one step of the process and
you know, it is it is a modular choice
at that that aspect, yeah.
Now, one of the things I want to kind of
highlight here, you know, about when I
when I start with scientific machine
learning, I say, well, you know, it's
it's you're pouring in model, you're
pouring in data, and your goal is to if
you have enough prior knowl- if you have
enough knowledge, right? Where knowledge
can come from data or it can come from
models. As long as you put enough knowl-
knowledge in, you should be able to get
a good prediction, right? You just need
to be able to hit the the prerequisite
amount of knowledge, right? Now, one of
the things that we've done what why I
like to start with this this epidemic
models because we had a lot of work
papers and such with with Sandia
National Labs where we dug into that
idea where we said, okay, you know,
you know, this is a choice, right? It's
a choice to say there's only one term. I
could have made two terms. I could have
made, you know, this entire part of the
equation neural network, you know,
there's there's a continuum of how much
model you have and how much data you're
relying on, right? And so, one of the
questions that we asked is, you know, as
you go through this continuum of more to
less model, does it actually work as we
expect, right? Does it actually work
like that like this big big figure,
right? Where the more model you dump in,
the less data you need. Or or another
way to put that then is
if you have more prior model and that
prior model is correct, you know, will
the universal differential equation be
able to give you better predictions from
the same amount of data, right? That's
another way of stating that same
sentence. And we have some work with
with Sandia which, you know, kind of
goes over a whole load of cases in
different epidemic models with, you
know, with simulated data and all all
these cases to really show that that
property tends to hold, right? So, so
you can kind of think that, you know,
this is something across the board
where, you know, with these universal
differential equations, you know, it's
not a question of like how many data
points you need, right? You know, a lot
of these things we're we're doing it
with 20 data points or 40 data points,
right? Um so it is a lot less data than
something like a standard deep learning
framework, but the real question the
real answer at the end of the day is the
more prior model that you have and the
more correct that is the less data that
you need. And so it is really you know,
it is really not you cannot say you need
30 data points cuz whether you need 30
data points is dependent on how much
other model you've put in there, right?
So so you know, I would say go you know,
go check out you know, the some of this
work and
I forgot to put in here that the work
with Sandia that really highlights that
this aspect that really just shows the
whole continuum of models and just shows
how adding different parts of the model
into it then incrementally improves that
that that extrapolation performance. So
but I mean that's that's in the general
idea here, right? The more prior model
that you have the more prior knowledge
that you have the better will end up
predicting. Um Now one of the things
that we've seen with the universal
differential equation stuff is it's kind
of explode in terms of how the number of
people really using it in practice. So I
like to highlight this work of of some
folks that you know, we we we we
actually have this now inside of our
inside of our
SciML
documentation and it's one of our
tutorials examples where what they did
was they they took these readings of
gravitational waves. This is the LIGO
gravitational wave data from the from
the binary black hole experiment that
first found the gravitational waves,
right? And what they say is they go
well, you know, gravitational waves they
come from black holes. Black holes are
big and so they didn't they're not well
defined by Newtonian physics, right? But
what if we assume that we only know
Newtonian physics, right? Which is which
is the equations that they have here and
we augmenting Newtonian physics with
with these neural networks to learn what
the relativistic corrections would be.
Can we learn what the relativistic
corrections to
you know, the the motion of two body
large objects directly from data, right?
And what they show is just that from a
small amount of data, right? So just
this small amount from the time series
here they're able to learn how to
augment the Newtonian mechanics with a
correction and that correction then
adequately extrapolates
for being able to predict the the motion
of the two body problem. It changes it
from being ellipsoid, which is a you
know, the the Newtonian solution to a
Lissajous pattern. And so if you're
interested I could pull up the the
documentation example of of doing this,
you know, it's kind of at this point
it's just like a nice reproducible
example that we use to to teach students
about how to how how to do this this
this process, but you know, it really
shows the scientific machine learning in
action.
But I mean there's a lot of examples
that do this. So for example, here's a
case with earthquake safe buildings
where the original model if you look
closely at your screen, you'll see these
dotted lines where you know, the
original physical model it it could fit,
but it wouldn't necessarily extrapolate
well, but after doing the training after
doing the fitting again, you know, the
improves extrapolation performance. And
then the interesting thing from that
though is that not that is improving the
extrapolation performance, but that the
but what you can gain from this process
is that it's told you how your original
model was incorrect, which tells you the
things that you did not know before that
would be useful to know about in order
to do better engineering. In this case
they wanted to engineer earthquake safe
buildings and so this told them what
correction needs to be done to the model
in order to then understand how to build
a more
earthquake safe building, right? Again,
you know, there's there's two things to
this. There's there's the extrapolation
accuracy aspect, but also the fact that
it's improving what you know about the
model that you're trying to build. And I
think that that that that second aspect
is probably even more important.
Everyone likes to think about you know,
line goes you know, low low low cost
with
with machine learning, but I think that
you know, improving the way that people
build models, improving the speed at
which people get accurate models, that
is probably the the more important
aspect here. Now there I can I can go
through like 50 billion more examples of
where people have used UDEs,
but I've already done a talk directly on
that. So if you want more more proof
points on it, I'd say go check out this
talk
on YouTube. It goes into a lot of
interesting examples as well. I'm going
to cut it here and say, you know,
there's a lot of other examples that we
can that we can show, but now going in
go so so knowing that that people you
know, what what the general idea is and
how and and the fact that you know,
scientists and engineers are using this
in practice, what I want to kind of go
into more detail here in a mathematical
way is you know, what what are the other
things that you can do beyond the basics
of it, right? So that really was just
showing the
showing the basics, but what are some
things you know, that you can do to get
creative with the UDE formalism, right?
And I I think that you know, I really
want to kind of show is that you know,
the formalism really allows for
generally imposing prior known
structure. So what what what do I mean
by that? So
here's a case that comes from that that
same epidemic line of work that we're
talking about where I said you know, you
have this continuum of models, right? So
here's something that lives in this
continuum of models where you might not
know that much prior information, but
you you you know, but you can impose a
lot of the details. So here for example,
you know, let's say we wanted to model
something like the SIRD case, right? So
susceptible becomes infected, infected
either recovers or dies, right? Um
So so what you can do in this case is
you know,
you can walk into a new situation and as
a modeler you can very easily know like
oh, people who are susceptible become
infected and infected people recover or
they die.
That's not a very strong assumption,
right? But but it is it is. I mean it's
a graphical relationship, right? It's
basically saying susceptible people do
not recover without getting infected
first, right?
So can you encode that that that
graphical information into a machine
learning structure so that way that is
prior known information, right? The UDE
formalism is is very flexible, right?
It's just you know, you put universal
function approximators in differential
equations in in in smart ways. So here
for example is a way to do this, right?
So you can have a neural network SI,
right? You know, so we have three neural
networks. So here's one function
approximator. So we say there's some
function I don't know where you subtract
it here and you add it here. There's
another function I don't know, which is
you subtract it here and you add it back
here. Then there's a third one, right?
So there's three functions I don't know,
but these are the places where these
three functions go and by design what
happen what needs to be true about this
then is you know, well again, there's a
lot of properties that I've just imposed
here. For example, the number of
individuals who the sub number
susceptible individuals is always
decreasing. Um you're going to have a
peak in I, right? There's a lot of
properties about an epidemic that I've
already imposed directly only from this
information. There's there's no prior
equations really written down, just
structure written down, right? And and
so what what what we're able to show
from this is that you can then you know,
do the this do the training of the
neural networks in this case, right? You
train the neural networks and then you
do the the sparse identification of the
dynamics. Um and you're able to then
recover what the what the exact
equations were, right? So we can you
know, simulate data, we generate the
data, we we then fit back to it and then
we see that we can directly predict what
these equations are, but importantly
what we can show is that you can do this
direct you can accurately recover the
equations using this form with less data
points and with less
with less data points than what would be
required than directly doing something
like you know, the the direct Cindy like
the the Steven Brunton
sparse identification approach, right?
So cuz you know, why why why is that the
case? Well, because we've imposed prior
information here and so we we've really
brought down the the structure that
we've needed to learn and so from the
same amount of data or from less data
we're then able to recover the same
equations, right? And so
this starts to show you that you can
start to get very crafty with the the
types of ways that they that you're
putting together function approximators
and using you know, any any drop of
prior information that you have.
Um so another example that that came up
which recently was actually published
into Journal of Chemical Engineering if
I remember correctly
is is a case where we have the this
chemical reactor and we're running a
chemical component over it. So there
there is one chemical that is flowing
with a with an advection diffusion
process and then there's another
chemical which is non-spatial. So it's
just a just an ODE process and they're
interacting, right? We don't know what
this interaction is. So what we do is we
model that interaction with an with an
with a neural network, but we know a lot
about the rest of the process. It's a
reaction diffusion partial differential
equation coupling an ODE with a with a
PDE term, right? And now one of the
interesting things about this formalism
is by by design now, right? I only have
to learn an R2 to R2 function in order
to actually learn everything I did not
know about this model, right? So I have
spatio-temporal data. Like you know, if
if you think about it in the sense, I
have spatio-temporal data and from
spatio-temporal data
you know,
you know, I have n by n you know, times
t time points, but at every single time
point the same exact chemical reaction
equation should be occurring. And so
what I want to learn is I just want to
learn what that chemical reaction is.
And so even with a small amount of data,
so even with a small amount of time
series, that is still enough information
to be able to recover what the chemical
reaction term is. And once I've learned
what the chemical reaction term is, I
can extrapolate into the future and get
things correct because the the important
property was whether I had learned the
rest of the equation in order to
accurately model the the whole the whole
process, right? So, you know, thinking
about it like this, you know, if if if
you think about it as as though it's a
time series problem, right? If you just
say learn from this time series how to
predict in the future, machine learning
is never going to learn what you know,
how to how to make that the the the red
dots go through the red line, right? You
know, where the red line go through the
red dots. It just doesn't the the blue,
you know, the training data that we give
it is insufficient for being able to do
that, right? It's it's just not going
to, you know, you can look at the
picture and you can see, okay, you know,
machine learning cannot learn things
that it's never seen before, right? But
there is something that hasn't seen
before. It's this prior information of
well, we have all this this reaction
diffusion equations and everything
written down. And so, by by virtue of
writing down the partial differential
equation form, we've actually
transformed a problem of learning a
spatiotemporal process, right? Something
that is, you know, learning learning how
to output things that are, you know, n
by n to learning just an R2 to R2
function that is a part of a
spatiotemporal process, and we can then,
you know, under the assumption under
many assumptions about, you know, the
fact that this reaction is independent,
you know, the reaction constants are
independent of the time and location
where it takes place, right? That is
encoded by writing it down as a
semilinear partial differential
equation. So, by writing it into this
form, we've encoded a lot of prior
knowledge that has made it a fairly easy
learning problem that then makes it so
that way from small amounts of data we
can extrapolate. Um and so,
you know, you might ask the question of,
you know, well, what happens in this
case if when we do the sparse
identification? Um this one was actually
a fairly interesting one for doing this
identification because, you know, after
we do this process, we we we fit the
neural networks, the student went in and
did the the identification process and
saw that there
there are a lot of cases where the
equations were not exactly the same as,
you know, in well, when you do this in
the case of generated data, you generate
the data with with a known equation for
for for these these reaction terms, and
then you go and you say, I'm going to
run this process, I'm going to find out
what equations I get. And you see that
the equations are different and student
was not happy that that it turned out
like that. But we then we dug into it,
right? We we dug into it a bit. What we
noticed was that if you actually do
second order Taylor series expansion of
the of the different terms, what you
what you see is that the these equations
are lining up, right? Um the equate so,
it's what what what this really means
then is that the sparse identification
is not necessarily able to tell you
exactly the equations that generated
your data, right? Um because it's kind
of ill-posed, right? That's not
you need infinite data to be able to
really fully identify the function. But
what it can show you is it can show you
a simple function which is locally able
to match the right properties of the
true function, right? So, here when we
do the second order Taylor series
expansion, you know, the the two
functions are are pretty much lying
you know, directly
with each other, right? And so, there's
a lot of properties you can get then,
right? So, from the learned kinetics,
you know, for for someone who's who's
looking at reaction equations, right?
You know, you can say, well, if I have a
a Q if if I have a Q squared term, this
is a self-interaction kind of reaction
kind of term, whereas a QQ star term,
well, this is this is a a interaction
between them. In some of these cases,
the chemicals were non-interacting,
right? Um and so, so there there's, you
know, there there's a lot of different
information that you can pull between
the these these pieces just by learning
the the equations even if they're not
exactly the same form that you started
with, it is a form that is
representable, interpretable, and usable
for for doing the scientific process,
right? Um
and so, I I I do like to to highlight
that that this was a this is a kind of
nice case where we were using scientific
machine learning in an in an industrial
setting. Um so, we were working with a
Formula 1 team. This was the Williams
Formula 1 team where originally they
used a Gaussian process model, that you
know, so this is the original Gaussian
process model for being able to
model their speed over ground sensor.
So, the speed over ground sensors as
they drove around a test track, um they
would get this this data that would
basically tell you the orientation of
the car, um but that needs to be
calibrated using the GPS data from the
from the the from the test track, right?
And so, what you can see here is the
calibrated prediction of the car's
orientation from that speed over ground
sensor.
And the original model did not take into
account a lot of the physics of the car,
right? It basically just say, here's my
sensor data and here then is the
prediction of what the orientation would
be. And you can see it has a lot of
these, you know, effects which, you
know, it's the similar to the
hallucinations that ChatGPT does, which
is effectively, you know, it's giving
you things that are not
physical, right? The car cannot is not
actually moving like this, right? The
car's true orientation is the is the
color underneath, and you can see that a
lot of, you know, a standard machine
learning model does not necessarily need
to satisfy physics, right? It does not
necessarily need to satisfy the fact
that your car cannot just bounce around
infinitely fast, right? But what we were
able to do is we were able to put a a
very simple model of the car's the
vehicle dynamics and say, well, you
know, what we don't actually know in
this in this process is the relationship
between the sensor to the vehicle
dynamics, and so by putting it into that
form, you know, a form in terms of
differential equations, which naturally
would be integrated, that naturally then
smoothed the process and incorporated
prior knowledge about, you know, the
relationship between angular momentum
and velocity and these these features,
and that made it fairly easy to be able
to get a much more accurate prediction
from the same amount of data.
So, um so, I I you know, one other thing
to kind of then highlight here is that,
you know, so
what what is this UDE formalism? Well,
this UDE formalism, another nice piece
about it is that you can rephrase a lot
of other SciML methods as UDEs, which
makes it a very nice form as as someone
who writes computational software to
kind of formalize around. So, here for
example is is a nice example of this.
So, um there's work done by Han Jensen
and and Lu and A, which is on
methods for very high-dimensional
semilinear parabolic partial
differential equations.
And they had this method where they
talked about how you can, you know,
solve these PDEs by using neural
networks
embedded within backwards stochastic
differential equations. Um
I'll I'll I'll skip over the the exact
details of this whole process, but
essentially it's this is one of these
scientific machine learning methods for
solving a PDE using neural networks in a
specific way. And they came up with this
this formalism where they'd say, you
know, you build this this recurrent
neural network, you train it with
respect to a given
with respect to a given cost function,
and then you'll have something that will
be predicting your your your your your
PDE solution, right? Um now, the the
reason why I want to skip over it is
cuz, you know,
when you start to talk about things and
and work with things in this UDE
formalism, it there is actually a fairly
nice way of writing down what their
algorithm is. Their their algorithm is a
universal differential equation, um
which is written as this SDE where there
is this function that it goes right here
that is unknown, and when you learn this
neural network and a neural network that
predicts the initial condition,
uh you satisfy a loss function on the
initial condition, so you solve this
stochastic differential equation in
reverse and you learn how to predict at
that initial point, um then you have the
the neural networks that give you the
the solution to the PDE, right? So,
there you can you can go and you can
show them in a lot of different cases
that a lot of of ways that people have
been looking at, you know, using neural
networks and mixing it with scientific
practice, the general formalism of it is
is as a universal differential equation,
right? So, this version of saying, oh, I
have this recurrent neural network, this
recurrent neural network that was
written down is simply the
Euler-Maruyama discretization of this
stochastic differential equation, right?
And so, you know, if you wanted to then,
you know, generalize their work, well,
one of the ways you can generalize their
work is just discretize this SDE using,
you know, adaptive methods or higher
order methods or, you know, all these
different types of approaches, right?
So, understanding what the continuous
object that that is giving us, you know,
the the you know, when when you do this
in the UDE formalism, you can write down
the continuous object for which the
discretizations give you these ResNets
and RNNs and and things that are then
used in a lot of scientific cases, but
you can then start to see that those are
special cases of a more general object
that you can then, you know, do a lot a
lot of nice you know, mathematics more
more simply on. Um and so, you know,
we've been building up packages for
doing a lot of these different type of
scientific machine learning techniques,
which really did then just uses
everything, you know, everything in the
UDE formalism. And so, you know, the the
core of the software is do UDEs well,
and then all these other cases are just,
well, this is the you know, this is this
ODE with this discretization, etc. And
so, it makes it very easy for us to be
able to repurpose the same underlying
training architecture to many different
problems.
Um I think that that's just one thing to
highlight as to, you know, we we think
about this UDE formalism, one as a way
to impose prior knowledge, but secondly
as a computational tool, similar to like
an ODE solver or a, you know, Newton's
method, right? It's it it's a way it's
it's a way to be able to turn the
scientific machine learning into a
computational tool that is then
repeatable to a lot of other
applications. Um now, I want to get back
to then the story of of differentiable
simulation, right? That's where I
started with and and so I haven't talked
about different differentiating
simulations at all yet. And so why does
this require differentiating simulator?
And well, the the thing is I haven't
told you anything about how I train
these neural networks yet, right? So,
how do I actually train a neural network
in one of these cases? Let me let me
show you an example this in an example.
So, here is a case where we're looking
at surrogates of of climate models,
right? So, this is a three-dimensional
Boston has to approximate Navier-Stokes
equation. And what we want to do is we
want to learn from the three-dimensional
PDE how to approximate its dynamics in
the Z direction, right? Just the just
the height column. Um we just want to
turn, you know, blocks of ocean into
just one-dimensional PDEs. Now, you
cannot do that exactly because, well,
you know, Navier-Stokes has curl
involved. You cannot represent curl in
one dimension. But, what you can do is
you can, you know, approximate it by you
can take the average, you know, you if
you take the original Boussinesq
equations you take it an integral
average along the the slices here, um
you can get an approximating PDE, but
that approximating PDE is missing a
term, which then is requires you have
another PDE, which has another PDE, etc.
Right? So, this is one of these closure
relationships that I'm sure a lot of
people are well aware of. And but
instead of saying, you know, oh, here's
a term that I need to compute from
another PDE, which is missing a term
that's, you know, computed from another
PDE. What I do is I just scrap all the
extra terms and I just say, here's a
term that would be computed somewhere
else, but let me learn what that what
that term is, right? So, if I did not
have the neural network, this is called
the standard convective adjustment
parameterization um to to the ocean
model. But, now what I'm doing is I'm
saying, well, the convective adjustment
equation is missing extra terms. Let me
capture that with with a neural network.
Let me capture the closure terms with
with a neural network, right? So, here
this is just the setup for for for for
my test case here. Um and now how do you
actually train this neural network,
right? Well, you can go back to your
data can say, well, here I have data
that, you know, I I get the you know,
average temperatures. I can take the
slice, you know, the you know, the green
slice, the red slice. I can take slices
on the Z axis to be able to know what
this average temperature capital T is. I
can do DD DTDT by taking finite
differences between my data points,
right? I can DZ DDZ. I can calculate
this operator by, you know, finite
differences. So, you can you can go to
your data and you can do all this
differencing. And if you do all that
differencing, you calculate, you know,
what is
del T del T and in what is the right
hand side actually. And then the the
neural network needs to be the residual
between what the data is giving you and
what the rest of this calculation would
have would have given you without the
neural network, right? So, so,
you know, what I'm what I'm saying here
is that, you know, you you can directly
go to your data, apply all the
derivative operators, and then learn and
build a data set that is then, you know,
neural network should take in this value
and it should spit out this value as as
the residual, right? You build up that
data set, you put it in the PyTorch or
TensorFlow, you you just train your
neural network, and then after you've
trained the neural network, you stick it
into your simulation to to correct your
simulation, and then you run it, right?
And so, what we did is we did this
process and we see that this this did
not give as good
results as any of the other things that
we've done with scientific machine
learning so far, right? In fact, it has
a very specific behavior to it. So, as
you run the simulation more and more,
you tend to get a drift that is
occurring more and more error as the
time goes on. So, why would this be the
case? Well, one way to understand what's
going on here is that what we've done is
we've came up with a process for this
neural network must be you know, my
derivative is incorrect, so this neural
network must correct my derivative or
control my derivative. Now, if you're
controls engineer if you and you hear
that term, that, you know, we're we're
only applying control to a neural
network control to our derivative and
then we are getting a drift term, it
should be immediately apparent that one
of the things that we're missing is
something like an integral term that
pulls us that makes sure that we don't
have this drift, right? Now, another way
of thinking about this is the process
of, you know, munging your data set to
be able to get a data set to train the
neural network has nothing to do with
the simulation process. Yet, the
simulation process itself is imposing
errors on the process. And so, if you
build your loss function and train your
neural network and then stick it in your
simulator, you're not accounting for all
of the properties that your simulation
process will also impose. And so,
therefore, you
you're you're training your neural
network without all of the information
that it needed to be the correct the
correct correction, right? Either way
you think about it, you you you end up
in the same point where the right thing
to do is instead of training on the
derivative data directly, what you want
to do is you want to, you know, what you
want to do is you want to directly use
the temperature data, right? This
average temperature data. Write a loss
function down where you solve your model
with the neural network embedded with it
and you check whether it's hitting the
right temperature values.
If not, you gradient descent and you
change your neural network until it is,
right? So, instead of training on the
derivative terms, you're training on the
integral of the neural network inside of
your your inside of your your your
model. And what happens when you do this
difference is you get about two to three
orders of magnitude better performance
and better fits.
Right? And so, you know, why the other
way to understand this, of course, is
that, you know, your your your
simulation process is imposing its own
errors, its discretization errors, and
all these properties. And this training
process is actually using the simulator
as part of the loss function definition
and making sure that it's correcting for
that. So, that way when you actually do
the fit, you know, you're you're getting
something that it that is
correcting for for any of these other
errors that you've imposed in that
simulation process, right? Now,
either way we've we've now ended up in
this formalism where we say, well, you
know, fitting neural networks on data
outside of simulators and then sticking
them into your simulators, right? Does
not give as good results as fitting
neural networks as part of the
simulation process. But, how do you fit
things as part of a simulation process?
Well, then that means you have to have
your loss function
be something that solves solves the PDE
defined by the neural network as part of
it. And we have to do then is you have
to take the whenever you want to take
the gradient descent step, you have to
take the derivative of the solution of
the PDE with respect to the neural
network parameters. And this is that
differentiable simulation aspect.
Um
And so, how do you actually do that
process? Well, you know, we say the
adjoint method, but the adjoint method
is actually a there is a lot more than
just one adjoint method. Um and it's,
you know, so let me let me describe that
this in one way. So, um the best way to
describe that there's more than one
adjoint method is to show you that you
cannot just use one choice, you know,
one popular choice for all problems,
right? So, here for example, uh the
neural ordinary differential equations
paper describes one adjoint method,
which is if you have a an ODE, U prime
equals f of U T, sorry, that Z should be
U. Um you solve this ODE going forwards
and it says if if you solve this ODE,
then you can solve this ODE in reverse
and it magically it will give this this
last term or this term right here gives
you the derivative of your neural
network with respect to parameters,
right? And it all it does is it it
relies on this numerical or this
mathematical property that if you solve
an ODE going forwards, you know, U prime
equals f going forwards, then solving U
prime equals minus f in reverse should
give put you brought back on on in the
same place, right? Um so, that's a
property that is true mathematically,
but if you actually look at real
equations, uh that doesn't necessarily
numerically work out. So, for example,
here here if we look at the advection
equation, if you discretize the
advection equation, remember, you have
to choose a way to discretize, either
using the forward point or the reverse
point, you know, upwinding or
downwinding. Um
and so, if your if your wave, you know,
if if this PDE is describing a wave
that's moving to the right, you're
either choosing, you know, that your
next value to the right is using your
information from the right or
information from the left. It should be
obvious that if you don't ever use the
point from the left to update the point
to the right,
cannot actually it does not actually
have the actual resolution
for for this motion. And so, one of
these is unconditionally unstable. Now,
the issue with with using an adjoint
method as described like this is it
says, well, if you solve the ODE going
forwards, now we're going to use as part
of our adjoint approach that if you
solve the ODE going backwards with U
prime equals minus f, you will, you
know, you use that as part of this this
adjoint derivation. The issue with that
when you apply it to something like this
partial differential equation is that
that is not true for this PDE, right?
So, if you solve this PDE, right? So, we
discretize this PDE into set of ODEs,
say the upwinding equation, you solve it
going forwards, right? If you reverse
the process,
um you know, U prime equals minus f.
When you when you reverse this process,
the reverse solve will be downwinding
and therefore, you know, you will have
chosen the wrong the wrong direction and
get
unconditional instability, right? And
so, what this really highlights then is
that, you know, there isn't really just
one adjoint method, right? So, this
paper talks about, you know, here is a
way to differentiate ODE solutions,
which has O of one memory. It turns out
that it has O of one memory, but the
downs it has a downside that it is not
stiffly accurate. So, it's not accurate
on stiff equations and it is, you know,
and it's not able to handle cases like
the advection equation, right? So,
instead what you need to think about
with this with with differentiating, you
know, the these these
differential equation solvers and other
equation solvers is that the adjoint
methods and the way of calculating
derivatives, they are approximating
equations themselves and so they have
numerical properties. And so similar to
how with an ODE solver, you have to
choose, you know, do I have a non-stiff
or a stiff ODE, and yet these these
methods have different properties, they
have different, you know, scaling
properties and different stability.
Similarly, you have in when you start
looking at the derivative approaches,
you have the ways to calculate
derivatives of these differential
equations, um you also have changes in
in the the in the properties where, you
know, there are some methods which are
stable, uh but require more memory.
There's some methods that are stable and
require more compute. And there are
methods that are unstable, but use less
memory and less compute. And so you have
this engineering trade-off between the
different ways and the different methods
for for differentiating systems. Um
you know, and you don't just have a a
trade-off in terms of stability, you
also can show that some of these methods
have scaling which is cubic with respect
to parameters, which can be fixed by
doing all sorts of different tricks. So,
this is the paper stiff neural ordinary
differential equations that goes into a
lot of detail in the differentiation
process. But the key that I want to
highlight there is that, you know, when
you just say use the adjoint method, you
know, that's that's like saying eat an
apple, right? It's like, okay, a Gala
apple or a, you know, a Granny Smith or
a pink pink lady apple, right? It's you
know, there there are many that there
there it's it's it's like saying solve
an ODE with an ODE solver. There's a
whole world of different methods there.
And actually each of these ways of doing
the derivative process, it really
imparts different numerical properties
and different in different stability
properties and all these different
things that come into play. So, when
actually doing the UDE formalism, the
difficulty and the interesting part is
all in the part that I leave out of the
the the talks, which is, you know, the
how do you do it stably? It's all in the
mathematics of the derivative
calculations. Um but the the key then is
that you can you can do the UDE approach
on any kind of simulation process that
you can differentiate. So, this is what
we've been building out as the JuliaSyML
ecosystem, which is, you know, doing
things like linear solves, nonlinear
solves, right? If you could, you know,
you can if you if your model is to write
an actual, you know, integral, well, you
can mix that integral function with
neural networks or you can write down an
optimization with neural networks, a PDE
with neural networks, right? In all of
the different cases where you can write
down a mathematical object where you
knew the function, you can extend this
to the case where you have a neural
network. As long as you can
differentiate adequately with respect to
that process. And so what we've done
with the Julia ecosystem is we made it
so that way the whole ecosystem of
equation solvers all connect with the
machine learning tools so that way you
can do this this universal, you know,
universal approximator mixed-in modeling
approach to be able to generalize any
type of scientific modeling to a
scientific modeling that is augmented
with neural networks. Um
you know, and I want to I want to skip
ahead here to to to this one one one
beat. You know, so so for example, we've
been using this a lot with Moderna, but
I'll I'll skip over with that and the
the story with with with chaos. I want
to kind of get to to this this last
story of, you know, very quickly, can we
generalize beyond ODEs and PDEs, right?
So, everyone talks about ODEs and PDEs.
What can we do beyond that? Well, it
turns out that that the the way to start
understanding things beyond just ODEs is
to look at chaotic systems. Chaotic
systems actually don't differentiate
correctly with with automatic
differentiation. I'd be happy to
elaborate on that in detail, but it
turns out that what you can do though is
you can define new forms of derivatives
and new forms of adjoints, which are
while the the derivative with of the
solution is not really well defined of a
chaotic system, the derivative of
ergodic properties with respect to
parameters is well defined. And you can
start to do things like fit neural
fit ODEs on, you know, time point values
that are more than a Lyapunov
coefficient away using, you know,
average properties of the system.
Um and so you know, and so this then
kind of gives you a generalization of
the UDE formalism to this case where,
you know, you have a lot of random you
know, pseudo randomness due to due to
the chaotic nature of some of these
processes in the in the error imparted
by them. Um now, one of the other
interesting cases then is can you do
this in cases like a discrete jump
models, right? Where derivatives are not
normally defined. Um so what we what
we've done is if you if in this
something that was recently shown at
NeurIPS was that um
you know, in traditional uh
differentiation, you you you take what
you do is you you take your equation and
you try to find a derivative. But in the
generalized sense, what you can do is if
you have any kind of a random variable,
you can try to find a new random
variable whose expected value is the
derivative of the expected value of your
original one, right? So, what you can do
is you can say I have I have some series
that that does some stochastic process.
And what I want to do is I want to find
a new stochastic process whose
expectation acts like the derivative of
my original process. Um and if you can
do that, which, you know, I I'm running
out of time here, so I'm not going to go
over the whole thing, but the idea
behind it is instead of looking at small
perturbations like, you know, small
perturbations, what you do is you look
at, you know,
small probabilities of having an O of
one change. And when you when you do
that kind of approach, you can start to
build out these systems where if you
were to have, say, an agent-based model,
you can directly run automatic
differentiation on that and get the
derivative of the expectation of your
agent-based model. You you So, if you
have an agent-based model, you can run a
process that generates a new agent-based
model for you. Where when you solve this
new agent-based model, the expectation
of that agent-based model is the
derivative of the expectation with
respect to parameters of your original
model, right? So, it's like some new
model, it's a it's a pseudo model, but
when you run this pseudo model, it gives
you the derivative with respect to
expectations of your original model. And
so therefore, you can use it to be able
to, say, train neural networks so that
way your original agent-based model is
learning the functions that would define
the rate parameters of your model. Um
and we're able to show this then in
cases like uh
extending, for example, um Conway's
stochastic version of Conway's game game
of life to something where we're then
able to fit the parameters inside of
there and be able to start mixing that
with neural networks, right? So, instead
of just looking at this world of, you
know, we have ODEs and PDEs, you can
start to say, well, we have all sorts of
different scientific models. We have
agent-based models, we have jump
processes, Gillespie processes, um and
and all these things. And in any case
where we don't know functions, we can
replace functions that we don't know
with neural networks. And as long as we
can find adequate ways to be able to
differentiate with respect to the
weights of those neural networks, we can
then learn what these functions are
inside of this process and then use that
to be able to identify the pieces of the
model that we didn't know. And it gives
us a direct generalization of scientific
machine learning to to that domain. And
I think I'm about at time there, so I'm
I'll I'll skip it skip right there to to
questions. Um
um
I see that I do have a one one question
here. So, in the Navier-Stokes 1D model,
what what what's the input for the
neural network term? Um do it does it
only take one grid point uh local? Or um
yeah, so for for that, um
for this case, we actually looked at a
bit at doing this in a way that is local
and nonlocal. It turns out that um there
is some mathematics behind this process
where it says that the they the operator
in general here should actually be
nonlocal in order to be correct. Um so
we we made this so that way the neural
network actually takes in the full
vector of the average temperatures. Um
and we
had another case where it was only
local. So, making it local is actually
equivalent to making this be acting as a
convolution network. And uh that did not
actually perform as well, which matches
up with a lot of the the theory then
about it being about the the closure
term being a nonlocal operator. Um yeah,
good question.
Yeah, thanks, Chris, for the talk,
everyone.